I want to sing a little ditty for my
sweet very short friend Rebecca who is
turning 22 tomorrow when quit I won't
give you something anyway never had
before
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's an amazing day in wine country when
was the last time we were all together I
just want this to feel like a regular
vacation and somewhere in there I'll
just slide into 50 age is just a number
what would you say your souls ages 18
old enough to drink and bone don't have
my own car yet but I have a bike
I made itineraries so everything we're
gonna do a minute-by-minute on the trip
we have lavender popping corn that's not
enough Molly huh I did Molly in college
but she went back to her boyfriend so
bring on the girls weekend huh just
remember guys whatever gets said it's
probably what the person has always felt
and the alcohol just let it out
this weekend is a mess I can't even plan
a fun birthday trip if you were just to
let go everything will just fall into
place will fall into place do you think
throwing the itineraries out the window
was on the itinerary guess I'll never
know
if we can't get to weekend together and
I'm completely lost
[Music]
that's what she said these women I have
known for 20-plus years and yeah
sometimes I want to tell this one to
[ __ ] off you want me to [ __ ] off that's
what intimacy looks like
this one's good what's it called again
white wine freakin love it
[Music]